Thursday night Caroline Flint lost her
seat in don valley to the conservatives
and she joins us now and devastating
result of course for labor at the scene
that you represented Dom Valley has been
labor since 1922 and yet this week it
turned blue why do you think that
happened well Sophie I it was because we
were fighting on two very difficult
fronts one was about Jeremy Corbyn and
the politics that he's espoused since he
became leader nearly on every doorstep
Jeremy Corbyn came up as a negative
people didn't trust him
they didn't believe him people from
Armed Forces families with connections
were worried about him and that
undoubtedly was an issue they didn't see
him as prime minister so I would have
people saying to me Sophie can you
promise me that if I vote for you he
won't be Prime Minister that's a
ridiculous situation for a Labour
candidate to find themselves in but we
were also fighting on another front and
that was brexit because alongside Jeremy
Corbyn brexit came up time and time
again to and the antagonism towards the
Labour Party and particularly the
parliamentary Labour Party as well and
seeing as as frustrating brexit becoming
an overtly remain party literally was so
so negative met with such hostility that
it was really hard to fight on those two
fronts and I know people are saying that
oh the polls are showing it was Jeremy
it was Jeremy you know absolutely but
not just Jeremy the politics behind it
as well but it was also in our leave
voting seats our labour leave load
voting seats that brexit was
instrumental in losing Don Valley and
elsewhere and you only have to look at
that and anyone who says it wasn't well
they're in denial and we'll move on to
Jeremy Corbyn in a minute I just want to
focus on some of the things you're
saying about frack say and those leave
areas because of course it wasn't just
Don Valley great Grimsby labour since 91
five went conservative Wakefield labor
since 1932
Bryce Valley which has never been
anything other than labor these real
former heartlands voting for the
Conservative Party do you feel that some
of your colleagues really understand the
concerns of some of those former labor
voters in your areas or do you think
that perhaps there's almost a the kind
of the views of some of these
working-class communities have almost
looked at with a bit of distaste yes
we didn't heed the warning signs in 2017
when we lost places like Mansfield who's
the majority for the Tory candidate
there has increased enormous ly we
ignored it but we also ignored it back
in 2010 and 2015 this has been brewing
for some time and and I think in many
respects our party the balance in terms
of the voices that are heard has gone
too much towards the metropolitan cities
and university towns and away from these
core areas and it breaks my heart you
seem to see what happened you seem quite
emotional I am emotion about it I I'm
emotional I'm trying to stem my anger
Sophie in all of this but I am emotional
because I do believe that in the pursuit
of remain a number of people who have
been ardent remainders in our party on
our front bench people like kissed
armored people like Emily Thornbury but
many others Hilary Benn Yvette Cooper
they have contributed to sacrificing 59
seats I think I said 40 we would lose if
we pursued this strategy 59 seats but
don't worry we've got Putney and we've
got Canterbury with all due respect to
the Labour MPs for those constituencies
I don't believe that was worth it
you name check it's a chaos' timer and
emily Thorne without to people here
expected to run for the leadership of
the party what do you think would happen
if they either those two people or
similar remain supporting people from
metropolitan seats if someone of that
background became the next leader of the
Labour Party I don't believe anybody who
have been the architects of our European
policy in the last few years I think is
credible to be leader that I don't think
they can win back these seats and we may
not I'm afraid to say you know take it
we go we shouldn't take it for granted
that a change of leader is going to win
us in five years time if that's when the
election is called but I don't believe
there's any credibility for these people
these people you know Kirsten led us to
a policy that did not listen to lay
believe voices who urged caution he led
us down the path of a second referendum
and I'm afraid Emily Thornbury did as
well she said to one of my colleagues
I'm glad my constituents aren't as
stupid as yours I'm sorry it's not
acceptable and therefore we're going to
have to really look at what might make I
candidate for leader who it can least
steer us to a better place over the next
few years but we shouldn't we shouldn't
for one minute think that a change of
leader is gonna create an election
victory for us it's about brexit but it
is wider than that the policy platform
that we had was offering everything to
everybody and whilst many of those
policies were polit popular there was an
underlying skepticism amongst my voters
about whether actually labour could
deliver and I think that was felt
through other parts of the country as
well but this is a terrible time for the
Labour Party and for the labour movement
we're in an imperative reflection for
the Labour Party that Jeremy Corbyn says
he wants to lead the party through
before having that leadership race and
he's written today and in the Sunday
Mirror and also in The Observer saying
that on austerity and inequality we won
the arguments he blamed brexit he blamed
the media coverage and also falsehoods
for from the Conservative Party for the
pretty devastating to fee do you think
he's taking enough personal
responsibility no no look I've said a
number of times now and I feel like you
know sort of an ancient in all this I've
been there like party forty years
running out you know the crack record
that we just blame the media for
everything is pointless it's absolutely
pointless labor winner let wins
elections when the public have a leader
they can trust and believe in and a
vision that they're willing to buy into
and on both counts that clearly wasn't
the case and part of our problem is is
that in 2017
calming and and those who are
surrounding him were so so in off the
planet in terms of thinking that we'd
won that election and obviously we
didn't because he wasn't Prime Minister
but they refused to look at the
underlying problems that were out there
I mean interestingly Sophie I thought
about this quite a lot over the last
couple of days Teresa made did not have
a good general election but she sowed
the seeds in reducing majorities in my
seat in elsewhere that allowed Boris
Johnson to come in and pick up those 59
seeds and and in many respects the
election we've just had is probably the
election that Teresa may probably wanted
back in 2017 no we win elections when
we've got a leader people can trust and
believe in and a vision they can buy
into and whilst some of our policies
were popular
they just didn't think it was believable
you know free child care free dental
free board man oh and free movement I
mean it was all free and you know
working-class people you know what I
stopped to that sort of thing and it's
quite clear they didn't believe it
either who do you think should be the
next leader at the lower part of them I
don't think it should be anybody who has
a hand a hand in a brexit strategy over
the last
few years I don't think it can be Corbin
without a beard I don't think that would
be the wrong move as well
obviously we'll see some probably more
runners and riders come out of this the
only two candidates at the moment I
think are worth looking at are Lisa and
Andy and Rebecca long bailing but
they've got a lot to prove as well but
for goodness sake
I entreat my party we seriously have to
look why we lost this last election but
look deeper than that look deeper at the
disconnect with our working-class base
our working-class voters and and it's a
northern issue but you know what it's
also elsewhere in the country to 40% of
Londoners voted leave in 2016 I imagine
that a substantial proportion of them
were working class families who also
didn't buy into the European project in
a very similar ways to the families in
Don Valley and elsewhere and that that's
that's really it really we've lost a
connection between ourselves and those
voters and their values and what they
believe in and Labour's got to start
building a better relationship otherwise
it will never win okay Caroline Flint
thank you very much for being on the
show today Caroline Flint there MP for
Don Valley for 22 years before anything
has he at that last election